so then how did the directorial stance
with vishal roop come about because
originally you were just going to star
in the film no it was an idea which I
had this script I've directed films
before but it it's less work and more
pay than just the star and so I was
looking for that I mean having some good
time and getting out of the camera and
walking do the shot go back sleep read
write poems whatever we want but that
was not to be because that director was
busy and he had an opinion about the
film and then I said it's my story and
it's my time and I must take over and do
it so the the financial was ready to let
me produce it in sort of someone else so
I gotta produce direct act and given to
you can you tell us a scene in the film
where once you watched it you were like
yes this is why this is why I'm a
filmmaker and an actor this is it it's
our particular scene haha then a couple
of scenes but one scene which is what
the title means that's the cosmic farm
as a bishop could be the bigger the
magnified form or the cosmic form that's
what mushroom means of the world view of
things so there's a particular scene
which I would have shot it slightly more
differently if I had all the equipment
available but there are certain
limitations and so we've done our best
and that's one time when I that make
modern dollar and the phone because when
I had it cut when I wrote it I was sure
it's going to be a good scene but then
the logistics of cinema can always ruin
something on the paper but it didn't
happen we pulled it off and that was a
scene it's a warehouse sequence when
that came through sort of came together
and I knew that we were sitting on a
good enough
your position what in cricket language
is called a good wicket
you